foreign
[Music]
of January 3rd most of the company
headed back to our old position in the
woods overlooking Foy
a few men remained in the Blackjack
attached to D company to hold the main
line of resistance good luck ladies
nice knowing you
boasted a deep well of original content
that include the likes of The Sopranos
and Game of Thrones the latest additions
continue their prolific track record
with fan favorite series like Barry and
Euphoria HBO Max released in May of 2020
which included Brands bundled under the
Warner media division of ATT as well as
license content like the complete
collection of Studio Ghibli films
British import I hate Susie and 700
episodes of iconic BBC series like
Doctor Who the office and Luther are you
with me Titus Polo will you come with me
to Rome
yes yes sir certainly Titus Polo is with
me
and you are you with me
we've originally made a list for the top
10 HBO original shows and all of those
were ranked by Tomato Meter from the
critics but for this list we're focusing
on the audience score While most of the
more popular HBO shows will appear here
we'll see some that didn't make the
previous list we've done we've rounded
up audience scores for the best HBO
series and miniseries look Murray we're
just ringing wondering if the fellas
will be up for recording a charity song
for our event
worlds full of possibilities and
unfortunately I haven't spoken to them
for about three
years you don't know where they are do
you
well I know where they are either
they're here in front of me I just we
haven't been speaking so get ready to
fill your binge watching calendar as we
count down the best fan favorite HBO
shows
[Music]
number 10 Olive kitteridge
Oscar winner Francis McDormand and Oscar
nominee Richard Jenkins star in the
four-part drama all of kitteridge
adapted from Elizabeth strout's Pulitzer
Prize winning novel which spans 25 years
outspoken Middle School teacher Olive
has a complex relationship with husband
Henry a good-hearted selfless pharmacist
Henry finds her harsh and hurtful yet
each has traits the other doors but
their son Christopher resents her
behavior and hates his dad being a
victim the program depicts life in a
coastal town and the effects of mental
illness starring Francis McDormand
Richard Jenkins Bill Murray and directed
by Lisa cello Danko critics say all of
kitteridge's narrative Slow Burn
enhances fascinating performances and a
story worthy of its source material
foreign
oh dear God
are you dead
apparently not
have you been stabbed or shy
no
not that I know of is it your heart do
you think
okay
can you move I don't know
I haven't tried yet well
try move this one
all right try it on
I don't have one of those cell phones
you yes
I didn't bring it
well I'm gonna have to go back to my cat
and and drive for help no thank you
please don't leave me alone
all right
number nine The Sopranos
Tony Soprano juggles the problems of his
fractious family with those of a family
of a different sword the mob he sees a
therapist to deal with his professional
and personal problems which bring on
panic attacks he fights with power
struggles Affairs violence betrayal the
threat of exposure and a whole bunch of
people being whacked starring James
Gandolfini Lorraine Bracco Edie Falco
and created by David Chase critics say
the soprano smartly runs an emotional
gamut offering detailed character work
and riveting suspense while displaying a
flare for both comedy and drama
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
just putting in a few stitches to create
a nice closure
because we were so scared they almost
killed you for a stupid car I guess
nobody told them about the kind of gas
mileage that didn't get something I'm
not funny dad
number eight Rome
two Roman soldiers are caught up in the
historical events of an era that
included the death of a Republic and the
birth of an Empire they encounter War
political Intrigue assassinations family
tragedies and more all while surrounded
by historical figures such as Gaius
Julius Caesar Marc Anthony Gaius
Octavian and Cleopatra starring Kevin
McKidd Ray Stevenson and created by
Bruno Heller William J McDonald and John
millius critics say Rome builds slowly
but a laborious star delivers Rich
rewards in the form of decadent sets
delicious drama and a surprising amount
of intimacy
it has been an honor and a pleasure
leading you
I'm sorry we could not be better
you must look to yourselves now
save your skins
give my best to my mother
tell her
tell her something suitable
foreign
number seven Generation Kill
highly trained Young Marines of the
first reconnaissance Battalion struggle
with inadequate supplies bureaucratic
snafus and poor communication as they
lead the drive into Baghdad during the
first weeks of the war in Iraq in a
seven-part mini-series based on the
best-selling non-fiction book by
embedded Rolling Stone correspondent
Evan Wright starring Alexander Skarsgard
James ransone Lee terguson and directed
by Susanna white and Simon selin Jones
critics say Generation Kill plunges a
viewer into war with a visceral force
that still somehow reigned in by
masterful storytelling and a strong
command of period details I imagine
there's some of you think
we have to give wounded civilians every
consideration we would give ourselves
that is not true
the Roe say
we have to give them the same Medical
Care they would get by local standards
standards you [ __ ] zero
it's a shitty situation for us
but nobody put a gun to our heads and
forced us to come here
we're all volunteers
number six Six Feet Under
laced with irony and dark situational
humor the show approaches the subject of
death Through The Eyes of the Fisher
family who owns and operates a funeral
home in Los Angeles Peter Krause starts
his Nate who reluctantly becomes a
partner in the funeral home after his
father's death starring Peter Krause
Michael C Hall Francis Conroy and
created by Alan Ball critics say six
feet under his unusual setting provides
a perfect backdrop for the Macabre
meditations on mortality made by its
brilliant brooding cast
[Music]
foreign
dude we've been honking for like ever
let's go
yeah we're gonna be late
this is David what's the grip man
lightweight
[Music]
number five Band of Brothers
this series originally broadcast on HBO
tells the story of Easy Company 506
regimen of the 101st Airborne Division
U.S army based on interviews with
survivors of easy company as well as
soldiers journals and letters this 10
part series Chronicles the experiences
of these young men who knew
extraordinary bravery and extraordinary
fear based on the book written by Steven
Ambrose starring Damien Lewis Ron
Livingston Rick Gomez and created by Tom
Hanks and Steven Spielberg critics say
Band of Brothers offers a visceral
intense look at the horrors of War and
the sacrifices of the millions of
ordinary people who serve
foreign
what
you're bleeding that's nothing cap I
want you to take these prisoners back to
Battalion CP get yourself cleaned up
come on crap boys Joe yeah drop your
ammo what drop your ammo you kidding me
what are you doing okay
I have one round Johnny how many
prisoners do we have got 11 right now
sir okay
you drop a prisoner the rest will jump
you I want all prisoners back on
Battalion CP alive
sir
number four oz
inmates and correctional officers inside
the Oswald State Correctional Facility
nicknamed Oz battle for power and
survival amid warring factions and
explosive acts of Retribution much of
the show takes place in Emerald City an
experimental unit in the facility that
tries to emphasize Rehabilitation and
learning responsibility while being
incarcerated Tim McManus is the unit
manager of Emerald City starring Ernie
Hudson Terry Kinney Harold perrinu and
created by Tom Fontana critics say the
patient zero of HBO dramas pushes the
envelope in graphic content and
storytelling ambition but its Relentless
provocations dangerously teetered toward
schlock
your wife's dead
what
she was shocked execution Style
it's too bad yo all right real soft okay
real soft
there's more
what
she's family apartment with another man
a Ronnie Smith oh damn Ronnie how's my
boy
found a bed together
look I've scheduled some time for you to
see sister Peter Marie
baby my son he's fine
he was at your mother's at the time
God or anything I can do no no no look
do the cops know who did this
drug related
can I go to the funeral
see what I can do
foreign
Tales from the Crypt
based on the easy comic series of the
same name this can't be in stylized
Anthology Series where counts a string
of horrific Yarns introduced by the
show's muldering host the Crypt Keeper
episodes feature a number of well-known
actors and actresses including Dan
Aykroyd Malcolm McDowell Christopher
Reeve and Sam Waterston Michael J fox
Tom Hanks Robert zemeckis Richard Donner
and John frankenheimer are among
notables who directed episodes starring
John cassir and Kirk Douglas critics say
over-the-top Gore pitch black humor and
heavyweight Talent like director Robert
zemeckis make Tales from the Crypt a
perversely entertaining oft imitated
Anthology series
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
don't you know who I am it's me
[Music]
number two Flight of the Concords
Cutting Edge musical Comics Brett
McKenzie and Jermaine Clement travel
from their native New Zealand to New
York in search of love and professional
success both of which prove Elusive and
is semi-improvised comedy series
starring wrist Darby Brett McKenzie and
Jermaine Clement who both created the
show with James bobbin critics say a
slacker comedy classic Flight of the
Conchords sings thanks to the offbeat
lyrical stylings of endearing weirdos
Jermaine and Brett
attack
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] sorry man I couldn't see what
was going on from around the corner
hey sorry Jermaine we're just expecting
Missy Elliot was going to come and chop
my body off
this is Johnny boy mrsley this is
Jermaine hey let's go back to combat
positions
Come On Dave
how's your day
oh good thanks yeah
how's your day
it's good I've been in the ceiling most
of the day
great is your gang gonna be here all day
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Barry
[Music]
disillusion at the thought of taking
down another Mark depressed low-level
Hitman Barry Berkman seeks a way out
when the midwesterner reluctantly
travels to LA to execute a hit on an
actor who is betting a mobster's wife
little does Barry know that the City of
Angels may be his Sanctuary he follows
his Target into acting class and ends up
instantly drawn to the community of
eager hopefuls especially dedicated
student Sally who becomes the object of
his affection while Barry wants to start
a new life as an actor his Handler Fuchs
has other ideas and the hitman's
criminal past won't let him walk away so
easily starring Stephen Rue Henry
Winkler and Bill Hader who also created
the show with Alec Berg critics say PTSD
and comedy makes strangely endearing
bedfellows in Barry which proves more
poignant than its sketch show premise
before we get started anybody have any
questions
is it true you're the most gifted
assassin in all of America
no I'm not the most gifted assassin in
all of America yeah
Jordan of Assassins
we're all very excited to be learning
from you will we be shooting guns today
yeah
wait how many of you guys speak English
bounce come on Bounce get out come on
take a break
walk
euphoria
in American adaptation of the Israeli
show the same name Euphoria follows the
trouble life of 17 year old Rue a drug
addict fresh from rehab with no plans to
stay clean circling in Rue's orbit are
Jewels a transgender girl searching for
where she belongs Nate a jock whose
anger issues mask sexual insecurities
Chris a football star who finds the
adjustment from high school to college
harder than expected Cassie whose sexual
history continues to dog her and Cat a
body conscious teen exploring her
sexuality as a classmates struggle to
make sense of their Futures the series
tackles the teenage landscape of
substance enhanced parties and
anxiety-ridden day-to-day life with
empathy and Candor starring Zendaya
Hunter Schaefer Sydney Sweeney Angus
cloud and created by Sam Levinson
critics say though at times hard to
watch Euphoria balances its brutal
honesty with an empathetic and Visually
gorgeous eye to create a uniquely
challenging and Illuminating Series held
together by a powerfully understated
performance from Zendaya I don't think
this is a good idea bro it was you
already I know it was my idea but I just
I don't think it's a good idea anymore
so I'm trying to tell you it was the
[ __ ] great idea can you can you slow
down because I'm thinking you know my
mom I don't want her to freak out all
right I don't want you bro it's not that
far and like no we're good we can call
okay what am I gonna tell Gia though you
know like she's gonna wake up in the
morning she didn't think I'm missing
[Music]
good come on
it's gonna be amazing
[Music]
[Music]
Game of Thrones
George R.R Martin's best-selling book
series A Song of Ice and Fire is brought
to the screen as HBO sinks its
considerable storytelling teeth into the
medieval fantasy epic it's the depiction
of two powerful families kings and
queens Knights and renegades liars and
honest men playing a deadly game for
control of the Seven Kingdoms of
Westeros and the Iron Throne starring
Peter Dinklage nikolaj Coster Waldo Lena
Headey Amelia Clark and created by David
benioff and DB Weiss critics say it's
intricate storytelling and dark themes
May overwhelm some viewers but Game of
Thrones is a transportive well-acted
smartly written drama even non-genre
fans can appreciate
foreign
foreign
[Music]
and finally number one the corner Gary
Fran and their teenage son DeAndre live
in the slums of West Baltimore they used
to have a normal Suburban family life
until Gary and Fran fell into problems
with substance abuse now doing anything
to satisfy their addiction Gary and Fran
are strange and their existence is day
to day hand to mouth DeAndre has a
chance of escaping the abject poverty
his parents live in by getting his head
down and staying in school but he has
his own problems he's tempted into
becoming a drug dealer making his living
on the corner starring TK Carter Condi
Alexander Sean Nelson and created by
David Simon David Mills and Ed Burns
critics say powerfully performed and
authentically written the corner is an
unwavering depiction of Life under the
thumb of addiction and poverty
foreign
[Applause]
on a big Corner huh no I was just
passing through just passing through
a gun
why don't you let your partner search
is he going yeah
he's got a mouth but he's clean
I can see you looking out a window today
you're taking a humble
saying I can't be outside nope not today
that ain't right you're on my corner I
decide what's right
I get
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]